[Musik]
>> GÜNTER: Hey, Murat!
>> MURAT: Was?
>> GÜNTER: Während wir zwei Hauptschüler
hier im Kalten arbeiten,
sitzen die Nerds drüben im Büro und spielen Among Us.
>> MURAT: Was spielen die?
>> GÜNTER: Among Us.
Ein Videospiel.
>> MURAT: Verarschst du mich jetzt?
>> GÜNTER: Ja. Guck dir es an.
>> MURAT: Die halten uns für blöd, glaube ich, oder?
>> GÜNTER: Ha,
dich, ja.
Mich nicht so arg, aber dich.
>> MURAT: Jetzt, meinst du das echt ernst jetzt?
>> GÜNTER: Ha ja, geh mal rüber und guck.
>> MURAT: Ah, das... Warte kurz. Warte kurz.
Hey, das gibt es doch nicht. Warte kurz.
Jetzt drehe ich durch!
Das gibt es doch nicht!
[Musik]
Was macht ihr?
Hallo, Nerds!
Nerds, was ist los?
Was macht ihr gerade?
Was habt ihr gerade gemacht?
Was machst du gerade?
Was ist das?
Mach mal an. Mach mal kurz an.
>> BENNY: Recherche.
Nein, das interessiert nicht. Nein, nein.
Shop mache ich hier.
>> MURAT: Und was machst du, Lena?
>> LENA: Story auf Pinterest.
>> MURAT: Was ist das mit dem Handy?
>> LENA: Nein, das ist meins.
>> MURAT: Ihr verarscht mich doch gerade.
Wir sind da draußen auf der Baustelle,
wir frieren uns den Hintern ab
und ihr spielt hier Computerspiele,
Among Us.
>> LENA: Das stimmt gar nicht.
>> MURAT: Wieso?
>> LENA: Haben wir gar nicht.
>> MURAT: Habt ihr nicht gemacht?
>> LENA: Nee.
>> MURAT: Was ist das?
Was ist das?
Among Us?
Ihr verarscht mich nicht, gell?
>> AYLIN: Nein.
>> MURAT: Hundert Prozent, ihr seid ehrlich, gell?
>> ALLE: Ja.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Wo geht das noch mal? Online.
Public.
Wow!
Okay, ich bin definitiv zu alt.
Ich bin definitiv zu alt für dieses Spiel.
Okay, also ich bin nicht zu alt für Karaoke.
>> EKREM: ... two,
it's so crazy right now!
>> SALLY: I look and stare so deep in your eyes!
Und ich bin definitiv nicht zu alt für
Verkleidungen und Karneval.
[Musik]
Ich bin auch nicht zu alt für Mario Kart in Real Life.
>> SARAH: One,
two,
three,
go!
>> MURAT: Mario Kart, los!
He, was ist mit dir los? Was ist das?
>> SALLY: Und ich bin definitiv nicht zu alt für Anna und Elsa.
Elsa?
>> SARAH: Anna?
>> SALLY & SARAH: Willst du einen Schneemann bauen?
Los, komm und spiel mit mir!
>> SALLY: Aber ich bin zu alt für Among Us.
Ich verstehe das Spiel nicht.
Vielleicht erklärt es mir Samira
oder einer aus dem Team oben.
Hi, mein Name ist Sally
und ich gebe mein Bestes,
um eine Among-Us-Torte hinzubekommen.
Vielleicht sollte ich mal einen Livestream machen mit Unge
und mit ihm spielen.
Der zockt das im Livestream.
Deswegen.
[Musik]
Vielleicht will er dann ein Stück Kuchen.
Oje! Was setze ich dem jetzt drauf?
[Musik]
Unten
eine Schokotorte,
vielleicht Schoko-Banane.
O ja! Schoko-Banane so wie Maulwurfkuchen.
Und obendrauf sitzt die 3D-Figur aus Rice Crispy,
– superlecker! –
die Rote.
Und dann machen wir noch eine Kopfbedeckung.
[Musik]
Für den Rührkuchen nehme ich
vier Eier,
200 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
jeweils 200 Gramm Buttermilch
und Sonnenblumenöl,
zwei reife Bananen,
130 Gramm Mandeln,
– die werden gleich gemahlen –
250 Gramm Mehl,
50 Gramm Kakao,
50 Gramm Schokostreusel,
drei Teelöffel Backpulver
und etwas Zimt.
Okay, es sieht nach ziemlich viel aus,
aber es wird halt ein leckerer
Schokoladen-Bananen-Kuchen.
Ich werde jetzt zuerst mal die Mandeln fein mahlen.
Ihr könnt aber auch gern schon gemahlene verwenden.
Ich gebe jetzt hier einfach auch direkt
noch die Bananen mit rein.
Wie gesagt, die dürfen schon sehr, sehr, sehr reif sein.
Oh, da ist sie ein bisschen braun.
Das mache ich weg.
Und damit sich es gut pürieren lässt,
einfach noch die zwei Flüssigkeiten,
Buttermilch und Öl.
[Musik]
Und jetzt verrühre ich hier die Eier
mit dem Zucker, Salz und Vanilleextrakt
so ganz weißcremig.
[Musik]
Jetzt könnt ihr hier die flüssigen Zutaten kurz einrühren,
aber wirklich nur vorsichtig.
Und die trockenen, die siebe ich dazu
und hebe sie dann kurz unter.
Schokostreusel nicht vergessen
und vorsichtig unterheben.
Den Ofen habe ich ja bereits vorgeheizt.
Und ich mache die Torte jetzt 25 cm groß.
Später nehme ich die Ganaching Boards
und mache jetzt aber den Ring ein bisschen kleiner
als die Ganaching Boards.
Und zwar deswegen, weil ich später
die Ganaching Boards benutze zum richtigen Glattstreichen.
Also
am besten so 24,5 cm ungefähr,
dass so ein minimaler Rand hier ist.
Also ihr seht das auch hier ganz gut.
So. Das Ganaching Board natürlich wegnehmen.
Dann den Teig einfüllen und kurz backen.
Und in der Zwischenzeit kümmere ich mich schon mal
um die Schokoladencreme.
[Musik]
Für die Schokoladencreme, also für die Ganache, nehme ich
300 Gramm Sahne
und 600 Gramm Zartbitterschokolade.
Die Sahne wird jetzt einfach aufgekocht.
Das könnt ihr auf dem Herd im Topf machen
oder in einer Küchenmaschine,
wenn ihr eine habt mit Hitzefunktion.
Ich nehme jetzt hier die Kenwood.
Da geht es auch superschnell,
denn die hat ja ein Induktionskochfeld.
Hier kurz aufkochen lassen.
Normalerweise nehme ich mittlerweile Kuvertüre-Chips,
aber ich habe noch so viel Schokolade
in meiner Schokoladenschublade.
Ja, ich habe eine Schokoladenschublade.
Deswegen versuche ich immer gerade bei einer Ganache,
alle Reste aufzubrauchen.
Also ihr könnt wirklich jede Art von Schokolade nehmen.
Hier ist jetzt nur wichtig:
Zartbitterschokolade wegen dem Mengenverhältnis.
Falls Ihr weiße Schokolade oder Vollmilch nehmt,
schaut einfach in meinem Blog vorbei
beim Grundrezept Ganache.
[Musik]
So. Und jetzt kann ich die Hitze ausschalten.
Wenn ihr auf dem Herd arbeitet,
den Topf vom Herd runterziehen
und die Schokolade dazu geben.
Und dann kurz verrühren,
bis die Schokolade geschmolzen ist.
[Musik]
Die fülle ich jetzt um
und lasse sie dann schön auf Zimmertemperatur abkühlen.
Mittlerweile ist der Kuchen auch gebacken.
Den habe ich jetzt hier 15 Minuten abkühlen lassen,
löse jetzt hier den Ring,
ziehe dann die Backfolie drunter weg
und lasse den Kuchen komplett erkalten.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt mein Lieblingspart
und, ich glaube, auch Siamaks Lieblingspart,
nämlich die Rice-Crispy-Masse.
Die liebt jeder.
Und zwar werde ich die Figur oben
– ich kann die auch aus Kuchen zubereiten.
Gar kein Problem.
Dann backt ihr einfach mehr Kuchen.
Aber mein Team liebt auch Rice Crispies.
Daher wird die Figur oben aus Rice Crispies gemacht.
Dafür brauche ich hier diese Schoko-Crossies.
Ich habe Marshmallows.
Ich habe Butter.
Schoko-Crossies und Marshmallows in gleichen Teilen,
dann ein wenig Butter.
Und, weil wir auch Rocky Roads lieben,
– das ist die Resteverwertung,
die ich aus Schokolade gerne mache –
habe ich jetzt hier gedacht,
machen wir doch mal Rice Crispy meets Rocky Roads.
Also machen wir hier noch gefriergetrocknete Himbeeren,
Erdnüsse,
Salzbrezeln
und Cranberries dazu.
Im ersten Schritt schmelzt ihr jetzt einfach die Marshmallows
entweder in der Pfanne
oder viel, viel einfacher in der Mikrowelle.
So mache ich das
und werde in der Zwischenzeit diese Zutaten hier
ein bisschen zerkleinern.
[Musik]
Die sehen jetzt nicht heiß aus,
aber glaubt es mir, die sind richtig heiß.
Also nicht reinfassen!
Die Butter schmilzt da jetzt drin.
Und ich weiß, es sieht am Anfang ein bisschen eklig aus,
aber die Masse ist echt megalecker.
Da gibt es sogar in Amerika so einen Schokoriegel.
Und jetzt kommen die hier rein.
Man hätte auch eine größere Schüssel nehmen können.
Ja.
Und damit jetzt wirklich
– also das wird jetzt echt de luxe.
Aber ich glaube, ich habe es ein bisschen zu gut gemeint.
Ich nehme mal die Hälfte.
Und jetzt die Hände mit ein bisschen Backtrennspray fetten
oder mit Öl oder Butter.
Denn gleich werde ich das einfach nur noch verkneten,
aber erst, wenn es nicht mehr so heiß ist.
[Musik]
Die Torte wird ja so groß
und die Figur soll schon auch groß werden.
Und jetzt durch Zusammendrücken und Klopfen
diese Masse schön festigen
und in Form bringen.
Und das müsst ihr halt machen,
solange sie noch warm ist und formbar ist.
Ich glaube, ich mache gleich noch mal die gleiche Masse.
Denn ich will schon eine große Figur.
Also ich will da jetzt nicht rumgeizen.
Die ist so ein bisschen flach,
oben rund.
So. Die Grundform passt.
Jetzt mache ich kurz die gleiche Masse noch mal.
[Musik]
Das ist das Männchen.
Dann die Beine.
Ich glaube, ich drittle das jetzt einfach.
Genau.
Ein Drittel für den Rucksack,
ein Drittel Bein eins, ein Drittel Bein zwei.
Also diese Rice-Crispy-Masse,
die wird schon relativ schnell fest.
Das heißt, wenn ihr die zubereitet,
dann wirklich auch so wie bei mir
erst mal die Hälfte machen für den Körper
und dann noch mal die andere Hälfte für Beine und Rucksack.
Vor allem hier auf so einer Steinplatte kühlt sie schnell ab,
was mir jetzt, muss ich sagen, gut kommt.
Weil ich arbeite ja auch recht schnell
und kann jetzt hier praktisch das formen
und sozusagen hier die Kälte schön mitnutzen,
dass ich schneller vorankomme.
Aber auch bei mir,
ich hätte nicht die komplette Menge nehmen können,
weil ansonsten wird die Masse echt schnell fest.
[Musik]
Und dann habe ich im Prinzip meine Grundform.
Der Rucksack
ist noch ein bisschen groß.
Die Beine noch ein bisschen hinten kürzen
und hinten dann dicker machen.
Das geht so.
Und die Figur, dass die mir jetzt nicht zusammensackt,
werde ich jetzt erst mal hinlegen
und liegend fest werden lassen.
Denn die Schwerkraft sorgt natürlich dafür,
dass die nach unten zusammensackt.
Aber von den Proportionen her passt das jetzt so.
Zuschneiden kann ich es dann immer noch.
Das lasse ich jetzt fest werden.
Und sobald der Kuchen abgekühlt ist,
kann ich mich um die Füllung kümmern.
Und das erst mal
fest werden lassen.
[Musik]
Ich mache jetzt eine Quark-Sahne-Füllung aus
500 Gramm Quark,
80 Gramm Puderzucker,
Vanilleextrakt,
400 Gramm Sahne,
San-apart zum Steifschlagen
und Schokoladenblättchen.
Zuerst den Quark mit Puderzucker
und Vanilleextrakt verrühren
und, wenn das verrührt ist,
die Sahne langsam dazu geben.
[Musik]
Die Frau, die auch den Sahnebecher auskratzt
und sich dann Sahne
ins Gesicht spritzt
nach der Dönersoße.
Habe ich noch irgendwo Sahne?
>> JOSH: Da ist noch welche.
>> SALLY: Und dann pro 100 Gramm flüssige Masse,
also Sahne oder Quark,
einen Teelöffel San-apart dazu geben
und die Masse steif schlagen.
Die perfekte Sahnecreme!
Und jetzt noch die Schokoblättchen rein,
kurz unterheben.
Und dann stelle ich die Creme kurz in den Kühlschrank
und kann den Tortenboden schon mal durchschneiden.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich den Tortenboden durchschneiden
und zwar zweimal.
Das passt gut.
Der Tortenboden war halt etwas anders.
Dieser Tortenboden ist so ein bisschen fester, aber saftig.
Aber man muss sägen.
Oh, vielleicht schaffe ich es noch mal.
Also insgesamt vier Böden schneiden.
Dann nehme ich jetzt den untersten Boden.
Der kommt hier drauf.
Die Creme fülle ich in einen Spritzbeutel.
Ihr könnt sie auch ohne Spritzbeutel auftragen,
aber so geht es gleichmäßiger.
Es sieht schon cool aus da drin.
Schön!
Jetzt kann ich hier die Torte füllen.
Und zwar achte ich jetzt darauf,
dass die Sahnecreme nicht bis an den Rand kommt.
Denn da werde ich von außen
mit der Ganache einfach verschließen.
Und hier also ein bisschen Rand lassen.
Dann gibt es da noch einen Rand.
Und die Füllung könnt ihr jetzt so aufteilen,
dass sie wirklich in alle drei Schichten passt.
Also so ein bisschen müsst ihr sie dann
augenmaßtechnisch
koordinieren, dass es passt.
Ich gebe jetzt noch Bananen rein,
dass es wirklich wie so ein Maulwurfkuchen
– eine Maulwurftorte...
Maulwurftorte?
Maulwurfkuchen?
Maulwurfkuchen.
Warum ist das ein Kuchen? Das ist eine Torte.
Wow!
Ich meine,
natürlich ist es eine Torte.
Bei der Maulwurftorte weiß ich, da tut man sie so längs.
Mh.
[Musik]
Nee, ich mache Scheiben,
dass es nicht zu dick wird.
[Musik]
Dann mit ein bisschen Cremen bedecken.
Jetzt nehme ich hier den Deckel.
Und damit die Torte weiterhin glatt wird,
drehe ich ihn einfach um,
den Deckel.
Und so fülle ich jetzt die komplette Torte.
[Musik]
Oh, die Torte, die wird so lecker!
Ich sage es euch.
Die wird der Wahnsinn!
Okay, ich gehe jetzt sparsamer mit der Creme um.
Der vierte Boden, der war einfach zu viel.
Ihr könnt übrigens die Ganache
– also eigentlich mache ich es immer so,
dass ich einen Ring aus Ganache außen aufspritze,
damit die Torte erst gar nicht so nach außen runterfällt,
aber meine Ganache ist noch nicht kalt genug.
Deswegen mache ich es diesmal so,
erst die Füllung
und später kommt die Ganache so an den Rand rein.
Geht auch.
Schöner wäre es natürlich andersrum.
[Musik]
So. Und wenn die Bananen dann so abgedeckt sind,
kommt der letzte Boden drauf.
Aha!
Siehe da.
Und dann kann die Torte
erst einmal gekühlt werden.
Ich kann hier aufräumen,
gucken, dass die Ganache kühlt,
und dann die Torte rundrum bestreichen.
[Musik]
Die Tortenkühlzeit überbrücke ich jetzt
mit dem Männchen.
Hier habe ich ja, wie gesagt, schon den Körper,
dann den Rucksack.
Und eigentlich wollte ich den Rucksack
jetzt noch richtig quadra-
– also eckig zuschneiden.
Aber ich glaube, es passt so zum Comicstil,
dass es so leicht abgerundet ist an den Ecken oben.
Also von daher passt das.
Ich muss nur gucken, es einmal rechtwinklig schneiden nur.
Hier.
Weil dann steht es hier nämlich perfekt.
Das passt.
Und die Beine, die muss ich noch ein bisschen anpassen.
[Musik]
Das ist eine Rice-Crispy-Salami.
Dann
bin ich mit den Metzgertätigkeiten erst mal fertig.
Und damit die Figur später auch schön glatt wird
und mit Fondant glatt überzogen werden kann,
werde ich sie jetzt mit der Ganache einstreichen.
Das muss ich jetzt in mehreren Schichten machen.
Also ich streiche jetzt schon mal eine Schicht drauf,
stelle die Figur dann kühl,
dann kommt die nächste drauf
und so wird sie einfach nach und nach geglättet.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier meine Ganache
auch in einem Spritzbeutel.
Es geht auch ohne.
Ihr könnt das auch, wie gesagt,
vor dem Befüllen der Torte machen
und auf jeden Tortenboden
praktisch so einen Ring aus Ganache spritzen,
damit die Sahnecreme einfach nicht an den Fondant kommt.
Das lasse ich jetzt kurz im Gefrierfach
oder im Kühlschrank fest werden.
Und dann kann ich die Torte schön glatt streichen.
[Musik]
Guckt mal. Wenn die Ganache kalt ist,
dann tragt ihr einfach noch mal eine zweite dünne Schicht auf
und könnt dann mit so einer flexiblen Teigkarte
die Teile einfach schön glatt streichen.
[Musik]
Die Rundung da vorne,
die ziehe ich mit dieser Tortenrandfolie einfach glatt.
Ihr könnt auch einen Abschnitt von einem Joghurtbecher
zum Beispiel nehmen.
Hauptsache, ihr habt was Flexibles.
Kein Problem.
[Musik]
Jetzt werde ich hier diese unperfekte Torte
gleich perfekt glatt streichen.
Und deswegen nehme ich jetzt diese Ganaching Boards
und platziere die Torte darauf.
Ein Ganaching Board unter der Torte,
eins obendrauf.
So.
Und alles, was ihr hier jetzt an Lücken seht,
wird praktisch mit der Creme ausgefüllt.
Und so bekomme ich es hin, dass die Torte gleich perfekt ist.
[Musik]
Ich muss sagen, heute läuft es nicht so geschmeidig.
Heute war die Torte sehr krumm.
Aber ihr seht, auch aus einer krummen Torte
mit nicht gleichmäßigen Bananenstücken
wird gleich eine gerade Torte.
[Musik]
Sobald der Rand dann schön glatt ist,
könnt ihr das obere Ganaching Board nämlich abnehmen
und noch die Oberfläche schön glätten.
[Musik]
Ich musste halt gerade noch eine Portion Ganache machen.
Deswegen funktioniert
– es funktioniert heute nicht so gut mit dem Glattstreichen.
Aber komm.
Das sieht man am Ende hoffentlich nicht.
Aber, damit ihr auch mal seht
– ich wollte halt nicht zu viel machen.
Dann war es zu wenig.
Dann war es wieder zu wenig.
Dann dachte ich so: "Ach, jetzt hör auf rumzugeizen."
Jetzt habe ich im Endeffekt dreimal Ganache gemacht, oder?
Ja, dreimal.
Ja.
Vielleicht für euch als Tipp:
Falls ihr mal zu viel übrig habt, könnt ihr sie einfrieren.
Für heute habe ich genug gearbeitet.
Die Torte ist gefüllt.
Sie ist glatt gestrichen.
Das Among-Tierchen/Männchen ist auch im Kühlschrank.
Und morgen geht es weiter mit der Tortendeko.
Heute ist nicht alle Tage.
Ich komme wieder, keine Frage.
[Musik]
Ein neuer Tag.
Und heute ist ein guter Tag für Fondant.
Ich werde jetzt hier unten
das Ganaching Board erst mal ablösen.
Das heißt, einmal kurz die Torte umdrehen.
Und ups.
Denn das möchte ich jetzt nicht drunter behalten.
Ihr könntet es im Prinzip auch drunter behalten,
aber das Ganaching Board
ist ja doch ziemlich glatt und rutschig
und ich will nicht, dass mir später
die Torte irgendwo runterrutscht.
Außerdem will ich nicht drauf schneiden,
obwohl es sehr kratzfest ist.
Oh, sieht die schön aus!
Ich nehme jetzt hier ein Cake Board drunter.
Das hat jetzt den Vorteil,
dass, wenn ich die Torte gleich umdrehe
und ich mit Fondant arbeite,
muss ich die Torte auch mal wegbewegen können.
Wenn ihr es jetzt komplett ohne habt,
habt ihr im Prinzip den Tortenboden einfach unten.
Und wenn euch dann mal was wegbröckelt,
dann ist es halt nicht ganz so gut.
Deswegen nehme ich einfach in der Größe ein Cake Board.
Da kann ich auch drauf schneiden.
Das ist zwar aus Pappe und beschichtet,
aber man kann es auch mehrfach benutzen.
Also das könnt ihr einfach abwaschen.
Kurz ein bisschen Ganache.
Ich habe immer so ein bisschen Ganache noch übrig.
Die benutze ich dann hier so zum Kleben.
[Musik]
Und dann habe ich hier das fertige Törtchen.
Kleine Ausbesserungen vielleicht da unten.
Und dann kann ich schon mal ein Kilo Fondant
– da nehme ich jetzt natürlich Schwarz –
schön weich kneten.
Und zum Weichkneten benutze ich dann meist
einfach so ein bisschen Kokosöl für die Hände.
[Musik]
So.
Da habe ich jetzt ein Kilo.
Ihr braucht jetzt auch keine Angst haben.
Also es kommt jetzt nicht ein Kilo Fondant auf die Torte.
Aber man braucht natürlich zum Ausrollen ein bisschen mehr
und der Rest wird dann weggeschnitten,
kann dann gelagert werden
und kommt dann einfach bei der nächsten Torte zum Einsatz.
Also Fondant wird da ja in der Hinsicht nicht schlecht.
Und ich knete das jetzt hier schön weich.
[Musik]
Und wenn der Fondant dann schön weich ist,
dann schön ausrollen.
Ich mache das immer gerne auf Bäckerstärke.
Bäckerstärke ist nämlich keine Speisestärke,
sondern eine reine Kartoffelstärke.
Und die klumpt nicht.
Und die kann ich später ganz einfach
mit einem Pinsel wieder wegwischen.
Der Fondant klebt dann auch nicht.
Und jetzt kann ich ihn schön dünn ausrollen.
Ich habe hier auch so einen Fondant,
den benutze ich ja schon seit Jahren, von Decocino.
Und der ist mit Sheabutter, kein Palmfett.
Und der ist echt supersuperweich.
Und vor allem reißt der nicht und ist sehr elastisch.
Also das ist echt gut.
Dann kann man das schön dünn auf die Torte auftragen
und hat nicht so eine dicke Fondantschicht.
Wenn ihr so Luftbläschen habt,
die könnt ihr einfach aufstechen
und drüberrollen, dann sieht man die nicht mehr.
Dann könnt ihr die Decke hier kurz aufrollen.
Die Torte ins Bild holen.
Und falls jetzt die Oberfläche,
also diese Ganache schon ausgetrocknet ist,
also schön kalt ist,
– soll sie ja auch –
dann könnt ihr hier
mit ein bisschen Backtrennspray drübergehen,
damit der Fondant gut haftet.
Dann gibt es da keine Luftbläschen.
[Musik]
Dann kommt die Fondantdecke jetzt drüber.
Und ihr streicht jetzt im Prinzip von oben nach unten.
Also erst mal die Oberfläche glätten
und die Luft unten drunter wegstreichen.
Und dann zieht die eine Hand immer die Fondantdecke
und die andere glättet den Rand.
Und so arbeitet ihr jetzt von oben nach unten.
Wenn es dann aussieht wie ein Hut,
habt ihr echt alles richtig gemacht.
Dann schneidet ihr hier unten den Rest weg.
Ich nehme dafür immer so ein
– ja, ich nenne es eigentlich nicht mehr Marzipanmesser,
weil ich damit wirklich alles schneiden kann –
so ein Modelliermesser.
Das ist nämlich flexibel,
schneidet die Backmatte nicht durch.
Und dadurch, dass es so eine stumpfe Schärfe ist,
reißt es den Fondant nicht.
[Musik]
Dann nehme ich die Bäckerstärke
immer so ein bisschen runter,
kann es wieder zusammenkneten
und einfach luftdicht verpacken
und für die nächste Torte aufbewahren.
Dann könnt ihr hier die Bäckerstärke wegnehmen.
[Musik]
Und dann nehmt ihr zwei Fondantglätter
und belebt die Torte wieder.
Nein.
Ihr glättet die Oberfläche
und den Rand.
Und das geht halt eigentlich extrem einfach.
Vor allem, wenn ihr vorher die Torte schön glatt gemacht habt,
dann ist das im Endeffekt nur noch ein Kinderspiel.
So.
Wenn ihr die Kanten so abgerundet wollt,
könnt ihr sie so lassen.
Oder ihr nehmt so einen Kantenformer.
Dann könnt ihr sie so ein bisschen eckiger gestalten.
Ich zeige euch aber gleich noch eine andere Technik
ohne Eckenformer.
[Musik]
Und ohne Eckenglätter
nehmt ihr einfach die Torte,
dreht sie um.
Da machen wir nämlich dann die Upside-Down-Technik.
[Musik]
Die ist nur für einen kurzen Moment riskant.
Ui!
Eins, zwei,
hopsasa.
O Gott!
Dann könnt ihr nämlich hier
ganz einfach mit so einem normalen Glätter
die Ecke hier nach unten drücken
und sozusagen die Ecke so nach unten formen.
[Musik]
O Gott!
Gut. Dann ist die Torte jetzt erst mal überzogen,
kommt in den Kühlschrank.
Und dann kümmere ich mich um die Männchen.
Und dafür werde ich jetzt roten Fondant weich kneten.
Oder nehmen wir Marzipan?
Ich weiß nicht. Ich überlege es mir kurz.
Ich überlege es mir kurz.
[Musik]
Also ich habe mich entschieden.
Ich nehme Dekormarzipan,
weil der einfach lecker schmeckt.
Ich habe ja jetzt hier diese verschiedenen Teile
und ich werde jetzt zuerst einmal die große Figur
mit der Decke einschlagen.
Und da geht es im Prinzip genauso wie mit Fondant.
Einfach dünn ausrollen auf Bäckerstärke.
Und das ist schon so ein angewirkter Marzipan.
Also der ist praktisch zum Ausrollen,
zum Dekorieren, zum Modellieren.
Da muss man nichts mehr machen.
Eingefärbt war er auch schon.
[Musik]
Und die Figur könnt ihr jetzt entweder stehend überziehen
oder ihr macht es so:
Ich mache es jetzt mir auch ein bisschen einfacher.
Ich über sie so
und schneide den Rest hinten am Rücken weg.
Denn am Rücken, da kommt ja sowieso der Rucksack hin.
Da sieht man es dann nicht.
Oh, die habe ich jetzt gar nicht mit Backtrennspray eingefettet.
Aber ich denke, es haftet trotzdem gut.
Und da hinten einfach mal
mit einer Schere grob wegschneiden.
Am besten immer so erst mal eine Falte.
Und hier mache ich es dann so,
damit es ein glatter Übergang wird:
Einmal hier einschneiden.
Und jetzt kann ich das hier wegnehmen
und hier das darunter wegnehmen
und sauber verbinden.
Dann habt ihr nicht so eine Beule.
Das packe ich jetzt hier nach unten,
damit es einfach so nach unten nicht abgeschnitten aussieht,
sondern rund aussieht.
[Musik]
Ich setze jetzt meine Torte direkt auf die Tortenplatte,
auf der ich sie servieren will.
Okay, die Platte rutscht.
Ich lege jetzt das drunter.
[Musik]
Mir ist die Torte jetzt noch ein bisschen zu matt.
Ich werde die jetzt so ein bisschen
mit Fett hier,
so ein bisschen mit Backtrennspray abpudern
beziehungsweise bepinselt.
[Musik]
So gefällt mir die Torte richtig gut.
Weil eben war sie mir ein bisschen zu matt, muss ich sagen.
Und so durch ein bisschen Backtrennspray
habe ich sie schön bekommen,
>> ELA: Guck mal.
>> SALLY: nicht zu glänzig, aber perfekt.
>> ELA: Die passt mir fast.
>> SALLY: Zeig.
Nee, du kriegst gleich eine Kinderschürze.
Oh, hast du dich ausgesperrt?
Kevin hat sich ausgesperrt.
Der kommt nicht rein.
[Musik]
Ich mache jetzt hier so eine Galaxietorte daraus.
Kannst du vielleicht aus Marzipan
die Among-Us-Figuren modellieren?
>> ELA: Was ist Marzipan?
>> SALLY: Also so wie Fondant.
Kannst du das?
Ja, nicht?
>> ELA: Mit Fondant kann ich es besser.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Hast du gerade gegrunzt?
[Musik]
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Guck mal. Dann mache ich dir jetzt hier Platz
und nehme das hier mal weg.
Aber die kannst du schon so klein machen, so süß, gell?
Warte. Ich nehme das kurz. Ich mache dir Platz.
So.
Und ich kann nebenher meine Galaxietorte machen.
Ich tupfe jetzt mit weißer Lebensmittelfarbpaste
einfach kleine Punkte auf die Torte.
Und das geht am besten entweder mit einem Pinsel
oder mit so einem Balltool.
So ein Balltool, das ist halt direkt schon perfekt rund.
[Musik]
>> ELA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Ela, sieht das aus wie ein Universum?
>> ELA: Mh.
>> SALLY: Sieht das aus wie die Galaxie?
>> ELA: Hm.
Mama, kannst du das kurz zum Trocknen legen?
>> SALLY: Ja. Guck mal.
Hier kannst du es hinlegen zum Trocknen.
Ist das der Rucksack?
>> ELA: Hm.
>> SALLY: Cool!
Guck mal. Du kannst auch...
Achtung, mach mal so.
So.
[Musik]
Und dann
kannst du
da unten...
>> ELA: Das sieht irgendwie aus wie ein Zahn.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ELA: So.
>> SALLY: Guck. Die sitzen ja auch so.
Da kannst du so die Beine.
Du kannst sie so sitzen lassen.
>> ELA: Ich mache den einen, dass er
Handy...
>> SALLY: Dass er ein Handy hat?
>> ELA: Ja.
Mama, ich brauche noch andere.
>> SALLY: Und guck. Den Rucksack kannst du
so hinten dran machen.
>> ELA: Mama, ich brauche einen anderen Rucksack.
Warum liegt hier so was?
>> SALLY: Und jetzt muss ich mir überlegen,
wo die Figur drauf sitzen soll.
Ich denke, ich platziere sie recht weit hier.
Denn die Beine...
>> ELA: Ansonsten würde die von hinten wegfallen.
>> SALLY: Ja. Damit sie nicht runterfällt
und nicht in die Torte einsackt durch Ihr Gewicht,
werde ich die Torte jetzt mit Dübeln,
also mit Cake Pop Sticks, versehen.
So.
>> ELA: Darf ich auch mitmachen?
Vielleicht kann ich...
>> SALLY: Mh.
Vielleicht wartest du kurz.
Warte mal.
Und dann am besten mit einem Lebensmittelstift
hier kurz anzeichnen.
Und dann kann ich die nämlich kürzen.
Und wenn ich dann die Figur draufsetze,
dann drückt das die Torte nicht ein.
Achtung, Ela.
So. Eigentlich wollte ich ganz viele kleine machen,
aber der Siamak hat sich eine große Figur gewünscht,
ich glaube, weil der Siamak Rice Crispy mag.
Kann das sein?
Gut. Dann habe ich die Torte schon mal gedübelt.
Den Rucksack möchte ich jetzt nicht ganz unten anlegen,
sondern wirklich so ein bisschen erhöht.
Daher nehme ich jetzt hier Zahnstocher
beziehungsweise Schaschlikspieße.
Die kommen
–  ah, die sind noch ein bisschen zu lang.
Die kommen jetzt hier rein.
Immer noch zu lang.
>> ELA: Mama!
Ich habe die Hände gemacht!
>> SALLY: Zeig.
Oh, cool!
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt die da drauf,
direkt auf die gedübelte Stelle.
Ja, passt.
>> ELA: Soll ich dem noch Hände machen?
>> SALLY: Ja, warum nicht?
Und dann kommen noch die Beine dran.
Hm, hm.
Hm. Ja.
Aber, bevor ich die jetzt mache,
werde ich hier noch oben dieses Schild
– oder mache ich erst die Beine?
Ich mache erste Beine.
Und zwar habe ich jetzt hier so einen kleinen Rand gelassen.
Den schneide ich jetzt ganz kurz sauber.
Und jetzt kann ich nämlich
mit dem Marzipan, was so am Rand ist,
das einfach so ein bisschen andrücken
und in Form bringen
und dann entsteht da einfach keine Lücke.
>> ELA: Halt. Ich weiß, wie ich den mache.
>> SALLY: Und da ich die Torte jetzt
nicht wegtransportieren werde,
sondern weil wir sie zu Hause essen,
werde ich da jetzt auch nichts mehr dran befestigen,
sondern ich lege es einfach wirklich nur so locker dran.
>> ELA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Falls ihr die Torte aber wegtransportiert,
dann würde ich schon die Beine auch dranheften,
dass die nicht abfallen.
>> ELA: Mama, weißt du, wenn ich gerade gemacht habe hier?
>> SALLY: Wen?
>> ELA: Ich habe den blauen gemacht.
>> SALLY: Cool!
>> ELA: Guck. So ui-di-di-di-diu!
Di-di-di!
>> SALLY: Dann könnt ihr nämlich einfach
auch so einen Schaschlikspieß nehmen
oder einen Zahnstocher
und im Prinzip einmal hier rein.
Ich zeige es euch jetzt an dem einen.
>> ELA: Und jetzt machen wir meinen noch fest.
>> SALLY: Und dann eben da dran.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr dann das Schild rechteckig habt,
– ihr dürft es auch so leicht abrunden –
dann kommt es mit Kleber direkt auf die Torte.
Das ist ein essbarer Kleber.
Da wirklich einfach nur ganz sparsam umgehen.
Kurz verstreichen.
[Musik]
Die Ecken, die runde ich jetzt noch ein bisschen ab.
Denn das Ganze ist ja doch ziemlich eine runde Sache.
Die sind ja nicht so scharfkantig.
Perfekt!
[Musik]
Gut.
Um das Schild hier jetzt
so ein bisschen metallic-farben zu bekommen,
nehme ich einfach Metallic-Spray in Silber.
Und das kann man entweder sprühen
oder zum Malen benutzen
oder zum Basteln wie Ela.
Ich sprühe es jetzt hier in den Deckel rein,
kann dann so einen flachen Pinsel nehmen.
[Musik]
Ich nehme jetzt noch ein bisschen schwarze Farbpaste
und mische es hier.
Ich kann ja den Deckel gleich auswaschen.
Ich mische es hier mit dem Metallic.
Dann kann ich nämlich so einen Farbverlauf noch reinmachen.
Dann sieht es auch ein bisschen
– ist das ein Comicstil? Oder was ist das für ein Stil?
Schon, nicht? So ein Comicstil.
Nämlich hier unten ein bisschen dunkler.
[Musik]
Und jetzt fehlt nur noch eine Umrandung
hier einmal drumherum.
Die mache ich jetzt noch kurz aus Schwarz.
Und dann bin ich so weit fertig.
Es fehlt dann nur noch der Schriftzug.
Oh!
Natürlich die Banane,
die Kopfbedeckung fehlt ja auch noch.
Ups!
Ich habe sie kurz vergessen.
Machen wir Banane?
Ja, doch, weil es ist ja auch eine Bananentorte.
Eigentlich war ich ja gestern für Öhrchen,
aber nee, wir müssen noch
– Josh, zum Glück passt du auf.
Die Kopfbedeckung fast vergessen.
[Musik]
Diese Details sind halt schon so
das, was es immer ausmacht.
Okay, die Torte kommt jetzt mal ganz kurz in den Kühlschrank,
wenn sie von der Höhe her reinpasst.
Wenn nicht, kommt sie vor die Tür.
Ich räume hier kurz auf
und dann machen wir noch den Kopfschmuck.
Der fehlt noch.
Und natürlich vorne dann noch das Logo.
Habe ich eigentlich erwähnt,
dass dieses Video nicht produktplatziert ist?
Also die spielen das halt oben
und deswegen machen wir es.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt noch der Hut sozusagen.
Den kann man sich ja aussuchen.
Und ich dachte, weil es ja wirklich eine Bananentorte ist,
mache ich eine Bananenschale.
Eine echte Bananenschale wird halt braun
irgendwann mit der Zeit.
Und außerdem will ich es ja auch aus Kuchen machen.
Ich habe extra
in mein Porridge die Banane rein
und dann
– um euch zu zeigen, wie ich die Banane machen möchte,
nämlich so,
aber viergeteilt.
Denn auf den Bildern bei Among Us
ist es auch immer viergeteilt
und so ein bisschen mehr Comic.
Das heißt, ich nehme jetzt ein bisschen gelben Fondant
und, damit dieser auch schön aushärten kann,
wird der einfach mit Cellulose gemischt,
also mit CMC-Pulver.
So.
Das wird hier eingeknetet.
Und für den inneren Part nehme ich Marzipan.
Der hat nämlich schon die perfekte Farbe,
so wie ich es brauche,
nicht ganz weiß, sondern eher so vanillig.
Also ich habe noch nie eine Banane gemacht.
Aber ich würde mal so anfangen.
[Musik]
Und dann hat ja die Banane innen so ein bisschen Struktur.
Da nehme ich jetzt einen Schaschlikspieß
und mache das jetzt einfach so.
[Musik]
Dann,
damit das oben
– genau, noch ein bisschen einschneiden.
[Musik]
Und das gebe ich jetzt jeweils hier rein
mit Kleber.
[Musik]
Von unten sieht man sie ja auch nicht.
Deswegen...
So.
Aber ich drehe das so ein bisschen.
Deswegen...
Also die Unterseite
– ja, wenn ihr die Schale nur von außen seht,
dann sieht man es nicht so.
Aber ich will das so ein bisschen drehen, dass man es sieht.
Daher mache ich jetzt hier diese Struktur auch noch rein.
Und damit das Ganze noch ein bisschen realer wird,
hier noch mit Pulverfarbe in Braun und Schwarz
einfach so ein paar Schattierungen
und Flecken drauf machen.
Das mache ich jetzt hier mit dem Pinsel.
Und an manchen Stellen werde ich es aber auch
mit Backtrennspray machen, dass es so ein bisschen,
ja, eigentlich wie flüssige Farbe wird.
Und dann kann ich hier einfach so diese Schale,
die Bananenschale so ein bisschen nachahmen.
[Musik]
Also für so Feinheiten nehme ich dann einen dünnen Pinsel
und für die Schattierungen
nehme ich immer so einen fluffigen Pinsel.
Habe ich jetzt echt "fluffig" gesagt?
Ja, habe ich.
Denn damit kann ich einfach
hier schöne Schattierungen machen
und das Ganze schön verblenden.
>> SARAH: Es sieht genauso aus wie beim Schminken.
>> SALLY: Wie beim Make-up.
Die feinen Linien vom Eyeliner
ziehe ich mit einem dünnen Pinsel
und die Schattierungen mache ich mit einem fluffigen Pinsel.
[Musik]
Ich nehme den als neuen Lidschattenpinsel.
Aber einen anderen, nicht den.
[Musik]
Okay.
Seid ihr bereit
für die Banane?
Also ich hatte ja auch einen Flamingo auf dem Kopf.
Aber ich finde die Banane schon süß!
Weißt, liegt da einfach so eine Bananenschale auf der Torte.
>> SARAH: Ja, das sieht schon cool aus.
>> SALLY: Aber ich müsste sie
– ich glaube, ich mache sie so,
dass sie oben noch so ein bisschen...
Ich mache da was drunter kurz,
so wie so einen Kegel.
Weil auf den Bildern ist sie auch immer noch so
zylinderförmiger.
Oh, jetzt muss ich halt gucken, dass man das nicht sieht.
Denn-denn, denn-denn, denn-denn.
Ich brauche hier erst mal noch so einen Kegel.
[Musik]
Das ist lustig!
Und jetzt setze ich mich kurz an die Theke
und werde noch den weißen Schriftzug machen.
Dann bin ich fertig.
[Musik]
Also ich hole jetzt mal Siamak und Aline.
Die zwei sind ein Haushalt.
Warum sollen sie euch selber erklären.
Kommt.
Ihr zwei dürft probieren.
Ich sage das nur, weil letztes Mal jemand gesagt hat:
"Hä? Warum essen die von einem Teller?"
Dann habe ich gesagt: "Das ist ein Pärchen.
Die zwei, die gehören zusammen."
>> SIAMAK: Richtig.
>> ALINE: Oha!
>> SIAMAK: Megacool, ey!
>> ALINE: Boah!
>> SIAMAK: Ist...
>> ALINE: Die Banane, ist die echt?
>> SIAMAK: Ich dachte gerade eben, das ist...
>> SIAMAK: Ich wollte auch gerade sagen,
ob es echte Banane ist.
>> SALLY: Nee, die ist essbar.
>> SALLY: Die ist aus Marzipan und Fondant.
>> ALINE: Boah, krass!
>> SIAMAK: Krass! Die sieht aber ultraecht aus.
>> ALINE: Die sieht richtig echt aus, gell, von Weitem?
>> SALLY: Also ich muss tatsächlich sagen, dass
– ich wollte ja ursprünglich so alle Figuren in Klein machen,
aber die Idee von dir, 3D oben draufsetzen, war schon cooler.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Saugeil!
>> ALINE: Das ist schon cool, so ein Riesenmännchen.
>> SIAMAK: Also man erkennt es direkt.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> SIAMAK: Auch mit dem Hut,
was man sich da auswählen kann.
>> ALINE: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ursprünglich dachte ich, ich mache so Ohren.
Guck. Ich habe es da hingemalt.
Aber dann...
>> ALINE: Oh!
Aber das gibt es doch gar nicht, oder?
>> SALLY: Aber dann kam ich auf die Banane,
weil ich eine Schoko-Bananen-Torte gemacht habe.
>> SIAMAK & ALINE: Ah!
>> ALINE: Voll gut!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Okay.
>> SIAMAK: Aber die Banane sieht ultraecht aus.
>> ALINE: Hm.
>> SALLY: Puh!
>> ALINE: Krass!
Die will man gar nicht anschneiden.
>> SALLY: Das machen wir jetzt einfach.
>> SIAMAK: Rice Crispy drin, glaube ich.
>> SALLY: Rice Crispy hast du dir ja gewünscht.
>> ALINE: Oh!
>> SIAMAK: Cool!
>> ALINE: Ist da das Logo mit drauf?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ALINE: Krass!
Krass!
>> SIAMAK: Dann bist du jetzt der Impostor.
>> ALINE: Ah, stimmt!
>> SALLY: Was bin ich jetzt?
>> SIAMAK: Der Impostor, der Verräter.
>> ALINE: Der sticht ja immer einen ab.
>> SIAMAK: Du killst unseren Crewmate gerade.
>> SALLY: Oh!
>> SARAH: Du bist die Verräterin.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte schon immer mal der Mörder sein.
[Musik]
Wenn, dann morde ich aus Liebe.
Ich habe blind getroffen. Ja.
>> SIAMAK: Also jetzt als Impostor
müsstest du eigentlich leugnen, dass du es bist.
>> SALLY: Ich war es nicht.
>> SIAMAK: Ja. Ah, okay. Ich glaube dir.
>> SALLY: Wer hat den Keks aus der Dose geklaut?
>> ALINE: Wer? Ich?
>> SALLY: Nein, du!
>> ALINE: Niemals!
>> SALLY: Oh! "Ja, du" muss ich sagen.
Wer dann?
Siamak hat den Keks aus der Dose geklaut.
>> SIAMAK: Wer? Ich?
>> SALLY: Ja, du!
>> SIAMAK: Niemals!
>> SALLY: Wer dann?
Also das Backen ist ja das eine,
aber, das anzuschneiden,
ist dann noch mal das andere.
Ta-daa!
>> ALINE: Oh!
>> SALLY: Die schneiden wir jetzt...
Ich glaube, wir müssen tatsächlich...
Ach, ich schneide jetzt einfach mal da vorne rein, okay?
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> ALINE: Geht dann das Männchen kaputt?
>> SIAMAK: Da ist bestimmt Buttercreme drin, oder?
>> SALLY: Nee, ich habe wie einen Maulwurfkuchen
– Siamak liebt Buttercreme.
>> SIAMAK: Ja, Buttercreme und Fondant, beides zusammen.
>> SALLY: Das ist der Einzige, der alles in Kombi feiert.
Ich schneide jetzt mal hier.
>> SARAH: Und Marzipan.
>> SALLY: Und Marzipan.
>> SIAMAK: Cool!
>> SALLY: Ich habe einen Maulwurfkuchen reingebacken,
also mit Banane und Schokolade
und Streuseln.
Ich schneide es jetzt mal so
und später schneide ich ein schönes Stück.
>> SIAMAK: Fondantschneiden sieht immer so cool aus.
>> ALINE: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ALINE: Voll satisfying.
>> SALLY: So eineinhalb Tage gebaut
und dann wird es zerstört.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: So. Jetzt dürft ihr probieren.
Wartet. Ich gebe euch noch zwei Gabeln.
>> SIAMAK: So.
>> ALINE: Danke.
>> SIAMAK: Bitte schön.
>> ALINE: Mach du zuerst.
>> SIAMAK: Nee, nee, fang du an.
>> ALINE: Mach doch du, du zuerst.
>> SALLY: Oh! Die sind so süß!
>> SIAMAK: Ja, okay. Dann fange ich an.
>> ALINE: Wir können ja beide gleichzeitig.
>> SIAMAK: Ja, richtig.
>> SARAH: Dann könnt ihr euch gegenseitig füttern.
>> ALINE: O Gott! Nee.
>> SALLY: Ach, kommt! Wie bei der Hochzeit.
>> ALINE: Nee.
>> SARAH: Jetzt komm.
>> SALLY: Dann können wir schon mal üben.
>> SIAMAK: Komm, wir probieren es mal.
>> SALLY: Wollt ihr eine Among-Us-Hochzeitstorte?
>> SIAMAK: Au ja!
>> ALINE: Ich glaube, das Stück ist zu groß, oder?
>> SIAMAK: Ja, für meinen Mund...
>> ALINE: Oder passt das in deinen Mund?
>> SIAMAK: Komm.
Aber macht man das nicht überkreuzt irgendwie so?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> ALINE: Aber dann füttert man sich doch so selbst.
>> SIAMAK: Ach so!
Bin ich dumm!
Ja, man merkt, ich habe noch nie geheiratet.
>> SALLY: Das ist beim Trinken.
>> SIAMAK: Ah ja, okay.
>> ALINE: Da würde ich mir auch Gedanken machen,
wenn du schon geheiratet hättest.
>> SIAMAK: Ja, komm.
>> ALINE: Also jetzt so? Okay.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> ALINE: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Und ich so mittendrin.
>> SIAMAK: Lecker!
>> ALINE: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich bin ganz rot geworden. Ich weiß gar nicht warum.
>> ALINE: Wir brauchen eigentlich noch eine dritte Gabel.
>> SALLY: Und?
>> ALINE: Mmh!
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> ALINE: Lecker!
>> SIAMAK: Das ist megalecker!
>> ALINE: Richtig lecker!
>> SIAMAK: Die Banane kommt saugut.
>> SALLY: Sehr gut.
>> ALINE: Hm.
>> SALLY: Das sind auch viele Bananen.
>> ALINE: Woah!
>> SALLY: Wir erinnern uns zurück
an das Füllen der Torte.
>> ALINE: Ich glaube, Marcel ist gerade neidisch.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja, wir frieren was ein für Marcel
beziehungsweise schicken es ihm einfach nach Hause.
>> SIAMAK: Ja.
>> ALINE: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Das machen wir.
>> SIAMAK: Der isst es immer.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Okay. Also das war,
ja, das Video zur Among-Us-Torte.
>> SIAMAK: Hm.
>> SALLY: So.
>> SIAMAK: Saucool gemacht.
>> ALINE: Ich höre gar nicht mehr auf.
>> SALLY: Ich übergebe sie einfach an euch
und ihr könnt damit machen, was ihr wollt.
>> SIAMAK: Okay.
Wir bringen den anderen Crewmates noch was hoch.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> ALINE: Mmh!
>> SIAMAK & ALINE: Ja.
>> SALLY: Heute war ich der Mörder und Verräter.
Aber nur einmal wegen der Torte.
Also tschüss!
>> SIAMAK: Tschüss!
[Musik]
>> AYLIN: Hä? Nein.
>> BEN: Oder es war Ariane. Die ist die ganze Zeit so ruhig.
>> LENA: Du redest doch gar nichts.
>> AYLIN: Ich habe dich aber rauskommen sehen, Lena.
>> LENA: Nein!
>> AYLIN: Natürlich!
>> ARIANE: Nein, Lena war bei mir.
>> AYLIN: Ich glaube, Ariane verteidigt sie.
>> ARIANE: Wenn zwei...
>> BEN: Die stecken beide unter einer Decke.
>> ARIANE: Hey, wir haben nur einen.
>> AYLIN: Ich stimme für Lena.
>> LENA: Toll!
>> SIAMAK: Leute, kurze Zockerpause.
Es gibt Torte.
>> LENA: Geil!
>> AYLIN: Geil!
>> SIAMAK: So.
Das musst du aber rausschneiden, gell?
Nicht, dass es der Murat sieht.
Das ist so sein Alptraum.
[Musik]